hey everyone welcome to another hd video
um it's not going to be widescreen or
anything but it's going to be hd
um today i want to talk to you guys
about something i have heard recently
going around in the tech world you've
probably heard of it called windows 7.
as my first video on windows 7 and
first of all there microsoft from what
i've heard is considering racing
releasing an upgrade for previous
windows vista users for 50 dollars
if that is the case i will be upgrading
to windows 7 instantly no doubt about it
um
i've already i've been reading on
cnet.com that microsoft might release
windows 7 in 2009
and that they might make it a 50 upgrade
to windows vista
that i mean that's just unbelievable now
uh this does upgrade costs
have been i mean from upgrading from
windows xp to windows vista has not
exactly been the cheapest thing in the
world and it wasn't exactly worth as
much money as you may have as you may
have spent
knowing that there's going to be six
different versions of windows vista i'm
i'm thinking that the windows 7 premium
version might be the best for me
so
stay tuned stay tuned um when windows 7
actually is released i will be doing so
many more reviews on i can't wait for
the performance boost of windows 7 guys
so uh stay tuned and i hope to get back
to you on windows 7 as well as many
other tech topics thanks for watching
peace